and now for the nominees for best
achievement in costume design Alice in
Wonderland costume design by Colleen
Atwood I am loved costume design by
Antonella canna ROTC The King's Speech
costume design by Jenny Beavan The
Tempest costume design by Sandy Powell
True Grit costume design by Mary so
freeze and the Oscar goes to Colleen
Atwood Alice in Wonderland
this is the third Academy Award and
nines nomination for Colleen Atwood she
also earned Oscars in this category for
Chicago and men Wars of a Geisha
thank you to the Academy and especially
to my fellow nominees for just so much
fun to sit with at the tonight and have
been so supportive it's great to be part
of such a great group of people the
story Alice in Wonderland was described
by its publisher in 1865 as a story
valued for its rare imagination
priceless humor empowered to transport
the reader into a world of pure fantasy
a gift to us all the heart of any movie
lies with the director and I've been
incredibly lucky on this and many films
to work with the singular Tim Burton
Tim's imagination along with the amazing
cast Johnny's incandescent Hatter Mia's
Alice for all girls all times
Helen us the fearless big-headed Queen
and our crystalline snowflake princess
and Hathaway made my job a delight we
had the support of a production team
headed by Richard zanuck and Kat early
prowl and Felder supported by Joe Roth
Susannah Jenn Cod and Disney but I
couldn't have done it without my team
Christine Kent Ella and my entire group
thank you all very much
you